a lot of people think that the first
week of college you're finally an adult
and you have
everything under control but the reality
is first week of college
can be a mess
i thought college was going to be like
the miley cyrus movie lol
and so i just thought it was sororities
all the time having fun having
houses and partying all the time moving
to new york i thought college was gonna
be
like the movies where you know you're
going out with your girlfriends every
night
you're getting drinks you're you're
meeting new people but definitely being
a freshman it was
much different obviously i did not have
a lot of money so it was a lot of like a
lot of ramen noodles a lot of just
buckling down
in the beginning before like you really
find your footing in the city
another aspect of getting comfortable
with college is dorm life
it was a big transition going from a
small room at home by myself to sharing
rooms but i didn't really
expect for what we call the great bone
flood to happen
one night after i hit the gym i came
home
and i came and the entire building was
raining
and i was very confused to why it was
raining
inside found out on the 13th floor of my
building
somebody clogged a toilet where it led
to an explosion of the pipes in the
building
from floor 13 down everybody's stuff was
kind of ruined
this was kind of scary i was like this
is crazy because it was like a lot of
water
they rushed us to grab all our
belongings meaning i had to run 14
floors because i lived in the 14th floor
through poop water
to grab my stuff and my roommate and
dash out the building
it was kind of like a sour smell like
what you would expect i would say
new york city subway esque smell your
first day of college can be a little
hectic that's when you move into your
dorm you get to meet your new roommates
your ra
and the people in your dorm building you
may have to do a few orientation
activities like icebreakers and getting
to know new people
but once the night time hits that's when
the fun begins there's usually different
parties you can go to to celebrate your
first day of college and you get to make
new friends
second day is pretty more relaxed you
get to do whatever you want classes
haven't started yet so
walk to the dining halls if there's
multiple dining halls if you go to a
bear campus
maybe find some food that you like if
there's food that you like in
college campus dining halls on your
third day of college you're going to
start making friends with people in your
dorm with people
in your suite and you're going to see if
you guys connect
and you're going to want to like go to
dunkin grab some coffee or
maybe like want to go to a cute brunch
spot and like get to know each other
talk about classes that you share you're
going to be brushing off those social
skills learning how to
make friends again in a different
environment take it day by day so your
fourth day is when you get a chance to
buy any other materials you'll need for
the next week for example you can buy
different school supplies like your
backpacks your notebooks and just make
sure you're prepared with any textbooks
you may need for
class next week on day five aka the end
of the week
you might have felt comfortable might be
branching out going to some
organizations to sign up and whatever
your interest is
you might have class you might not have
class just depending on what schedule
you have
you'll probably sit in class and be a
little anxious to meet friends and meet
people you could probably connect with
to study later on
these are the days that most parties
happen sadly my
school was not a very party-heavy campus
they had parties but i didn't really
know about them at the time an important
aspect of college
is getting to know your roommates i
definitely uh got to know mine a little
more
during my first week of college i lived
with three
roommates we were all getting to know
each other you know the first week my
roommates and i
we went out the night before we're
having a great time
i assumed everyone was you know tucked
in their beds the next day everyone's
fine it was the weekend
around like three in the afternoon i
hear this knock on the door
and it sounds quite urgent and i just
assume it's one of my roommates who you
know got locked out i'm like okay i'll
get up i'll
i'll be the one that has to get up and
open the door i open the door
there's three cops already outside my
door i see two more down the hallway and
i see like the red lights flashing you
know
outside the farther i look there's more
piling in so i'm like okay
what's what's going on and so they asked
me they're like oh hey
do you know this person naming one of my
roommates and i'm like yeah
i do know them why what's up they're
asking me oh have you have you seen them
with a weapon any
weapons inside the apartment and i'm
like no not that i know of i haven't
seen anything with my
own two eyeballs and they're like yeah
we need to talk to them we need to talk
to them right now
and so my sister and i we go outside and
we're like we're waiting there
my heart is pounding you know i just
moved to new york city for the first
time
i have no idea what's going on i'm like
is this normal is this the adorable
saturday afternoon in new york city
eventually they're done talking to our
roommate
which i'm like great please let me back
inside my apartment ask my roommate i'm
like okay
what what what was that what was going
on there my roommate proceeds to tell me
their mom called the cops on them
because she thought they stole something
from her
i don't know why they needed that many
cops though for such a very small thing
but i guess it was super intense and
they were totally calm about it didn't
blink an eye and i'm like okay i guess
this you know
normal day and you're like safe to say
our roommate dinner that week
was quite awkward another important
aspect of college are the parties my
first week of college my housemates and
i decided to throw a house party we just
wanted to have
a small party but this party went
nothing like plans
some drunk girls thought it'd be a great
idea to throw some glass bottles into
our washing machine
and run the machine and when we tried to
track them down they got lost throughout
the house
this wasn't our only problem some frat
guys from the college down the street
broke into our house pulled out some
random matches from our basements
and jumped off our roof afterwards they
ran through the back
and broke our fence my housemates and i
started freaking out because we'd have
to pay for that fence
and one of my housemates got so angry he
picked up a baseball bat and decided to
go after them at that point
everyone at the party pulls out their
cell phones and starts recording because
they are ready to see a fight my
housemate gets angry and turns around
and almost swings the bat at one of them
until i catch the baseball bat
and take it away from him at that point
we all decide it's time for the party to
be over
so we send everyone home early and that
was my first rager
in my first week of college you know
sometimes in college you might
meet new friends or get your stuff
ruined by
dirty sewage water but it's college and
it's all about the experience you know
so your first week of college may not be
what you expected but
i would not change those experiences for
the world i cherish those and i would
not
be who i am today without those
experiences college can be a really
crazy experience
people may jump off your roof and
destroy your college house
but at the end of the day it was a great
experience it's something that i'll
always look at fondly and it's truly the
best years of your life i wouldn't
change a thing
you